[Music]
welcome everyone to the 2021 t-mobile
home run derby where we have elements
and the environment and the event
perhaps the most anticipated home run
derby ever all of that has to do with
the headliner who is shohei ohtani and
then you wonder about the local kid
trevor story how he's gonna do all part
of what makes this such an unforgettable
night mancini will step in 29 years old
well he's found the happy zone mancini
is locked in right now the number to 10.
he is doing a wonderful job of catching
everything out in front but he needs to
continue to throw the pitches down and
in right now and trey's absolutely just
crushing them what a start to this 2021
t-mobile home run derby a cancer
survivor listen to the ovation for
trevor story
11 home runs the fans he talked about
the energy he would draw from them he
talked about being accustomed to the
elevation and he really believes this
ballpark is better suited for
right-handed hitters i want him to win
it he's my boy he's putting on a great
show for the home fans
the fans deserve it and uh i think he's
got more left in him he's gonna be all
right yeah he's a dead hitter right now
home run total for story
20. did alonso the 2019 champion after
he won that then he showed up and drove
in a couple of runs in the all-star game
the next day the first rookie
multiple rbi's in an all-star game but
he lives for the derby lives for it
let's not forget the polar bear who just
keeps ripping
that's gone in a big way
and he goes to the crowd to get them
involved what a round
here's a guy who you remember of course
from his rookie performance in the
2019 postseason if i'm so you have to
get to 25.
25 is a number that'll put a lot of
pressure on ohtani and again 22 for juan
soto you just don't know
what the ohtani experience is going to
be like this is going to be special
right now and this is what a lot of
people waited for yeah there is a level
of amazement with what otani's done from
his ears without question
oh tony just apparently got words of
wisdom from his angel teammate mike
trout
that's it right there that ties it now
win it
he may have just won it with three in a
row i don't think that's gonna go we
have our first swing off of the 20-21
t-mobile home run derby and soto will
set the bar for ohtani and otani's gas
right now so there's soto has an
advantage where he had sat down waited
in the meantime ohtani is gas let's see
if that works for juan great effort from
the 22 year olds now it's otani who
joined the angels in december of 2017 as
a 23 year old
here he goes and shohei ohtani
not yet needs one
we're gonna have a little swing off
three swings junior now alan soto just
went three
four three
can't do better than that three swings
they've all got to lose
i think everybody feels the tension in
this ballpark and that will do it juan
soto
three perfect swings
to feed shohei ohtani how about trey
mancini right now coming up here's the
tying one for mancini the next one will
move him on and that's a shot to center
and that is gonna do it trey mancini
pete
alonso the med stands adore him
[Applause]
oh
he's gonna give it another run this is a
walk-off of seismic proportion ray
mancini who was in and out of the
hospital and chemotherapy with stage
three cancer
a year ago and trey mancini is doing
something on the field right now
that very few humans can do on the
planet mancini blasting off again 21 for
trae man seeing
[Applause]
it's rhythmic
he wants to go go go
what an effort from trey mancini and
these fans know
how much
of a feat of humanity
this man
is putting up 22 is the number feeling
good right now so far 60 of the pitches
he's seen
have left the ballpark in this round he
said again recently we're going to take
it home again i had a fun time winning
i'm going to win again
six wins it and now it's five that will
win it another massive shot from alonso
four to win it like a countdown
three to win it
two to win it he's not missing
one more to win it as alonso comes out
of the timeout
and walks it off what a finish alonso
defends his title the 2021 derby
champion
put the belt on again
what a show
ken griffey jr giving him the trophy but
alonzo
he made that look easy
spin it to win it derby champion
[Applause]